اول من عرض مخطط التقسيم المكاني والزماني
للمسجد الاقصى المبارك كان هو اليمين
الاسرائيلي متطرف بقياده حزب النيكود وذلك
تمهيدا لتهويد المسجد من خلال سياسه
الاقتحامات والاعتداءات المتكرره على
المرابطين داخله وفق تقرير مؤسسه القدس
الدوليه يخطط الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لفرض
التقسيم المكاني للاقصى عبر الاستيلاء على
منطقتين الاولى في الجهه الغربيه امام باب
المغاربه
وقربه حائط البراق الذي يقيم عنده اليهود
طقوسهم الوديه في زريعه انه حائط المبكى
كما يسمونه المنطقه الثانيه المنطقه
الثانيه تقع في الجهه الشرقيه لجهه مقبره
باب الرحمه والتي صدر الاحتلال جزءا منها
وهي المنطقه التي يؤدي اليهود عندها بعض
الطقوس وذلك مقابل قبه الصخره
كيف تتحدث مصادر عن تخصيص اجزاء ومساحات
من المسجد الاقصى يقتنها اليهود يحولوها
لكونس يهوديه لاداء صلواتهم فيها يشمل
التقسيم المكاني كذلك بسط السيطره بالقوه
على جميع الساحات الخارجيه التي تحيط
بالمسجد الاقصى الاماكن المسقوفه مثل
المسلق قبه الصخره والمصلى المرواني فتكون
للمسلمين
ليس سرا ان الجماعات الدينيه اليهوديه
تسعى لاقامه الهيكل المزعوم على انقاض
المسجد الاقصى اما مخطط التقسيم الزماني
فهذا بحث يهدف الى تخصيص اوقات محدده
لدخول المسلمين للمسجد الاقصى وكذلك اوقات
اخرى خاصه باليهود بحيث يتم اقتسام
الساعات والايام طوال العام بين المسلمين
واليهود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يرى ان على المسلمين
افراغ المسجد الاقصى يوميا وذلك من الساعه
السابعه والنصف حتى الحاديه عشره صباحا
في فتره الظهيره في يمتد الوقت من
الواحده والنصف وحتى الثانيه والنصف وفي
فتره ثالثه بعد العصر لتكون هذه الاوقات
مخصصه لليهود فقط
كذلك يسعى هذا المخطط لتخصيص المسجد
الاقصى لليهود خلال اعيادهم التي تصل الى
100 يوم بالاضافه الى جميع ايام السبت
يصل عدد الايام المخصصه وفق هذا المخطط
لليهود قرابه مئه وخمسين يوما في العام
ولاحكام السيطره على المسجد عاده يمنع
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من تقل اعمارهم عن
اربعين عاما من دخول المسجد وتحضر
المخابرات الاسرائيليه ما تسميه تنظيم
المرابطين والمرابطات الذين يقومون على
خدمه المسجد
تبلغ او
تبلغ اسرائيل عددا كبيرا من ابناء القدس
والداخل الاسرائيلي المحتل ممن يواظبون
على الصلاه في المسجد الاقصى بشكل منتظم
تبلغهم بضروره ان يبتعدوا عن المسجد مده
ما تزيد على سته اشهر تجدد بعد انتهاء كل
فتره